a guy who used to date Amy Schumer she's
married now but she's the date Kyle
Dunnigan he's been here helping us all
week right now doing little voices and
comedy stuff may I say you're almost
like a Pete Davidson because uh well you
dated Sarah yeah who was a very
beautiful woman you dated Amy yeah we
had a we had a moment there a moment I'm
yes I'm living right now with her and
her husband's yet to be careful
you're living with Amy and her house
after dating while ago is brief did you
ever leave her apartment or did you just
say I'm staying
I don't care what are you working on her
new show yes so you work out of her
apartment yeah mainly out of her
apartment so you're living with them
mm-hmm when I first got there was very
like oh you don't to do that I got so
entitled within two days like the soap
was low and like what is so khlo why go
check myself and say let's first of all
so how long you been in her apartment
I've been there for a month and a half
she's pissed off like you're not leaving
no she's been very cool of your own room
yes like a marble bathroom between and
like you don't run into her husband and
we we bro out really chests no kidding
and all the food is like really good and
free maybe I'll stop by I should cuz I'd
like to play chess kind of packed it is
yeah now I go I would love to play in
chess yeah be fun yeah
I'm supposed to leave in three weeks
bound think I'm gonna [ __ ] it mistake at
what point are you like a squatter when
they when Amy show is completely written
and there's no reason for you to be
there do you have a jerk off and that
play all the time yeah what do you do do
you lock the door oh yeah we have a lock
on your door yeah like the her husband
like we'll just kind of come in the
first time luckily nothing was going on
but I now I lock it excuse me I'm nude
in here this is I've got to get out of
it because this is like suspended
adolescence I've got a temporary
anything guys were right for me if they
showed up my apartment I tase them I'm
not inviting them in yeah but she's
pretty cool that way very cool